double congratulations you just reveals
you're three months pregnant yeah you
know everyone's asked me what are you
gonna do now and it's like all right it
feels like a right time to say that like
this makes me so happy and this makes me
happy so you did not plan on sharing
that news to them like 50/50 I'm at the
three-month mark so it was like a good
time to share stuff but also might as
well do it in the present if present I
don't know is that gross I looked at
Jack to see if it was gross and Jack did
not give me like Jack is not the father
of my baby I should say but I looked at
I was like I mean [ __ ] just everyone was
like what's next for you right and it
just feels like everyone knows the
secret and so I just was like tell
people even I yes but little did I know
his motherhood motherhood is in addition
to many many many things and it's very
very cool to be able to tell my someday
daughter they're like she was on stage
with me when I was doing that opening
number she won an Emmy with me she will
be evil like a mother
listen if Beyonce could reveal she's
pregnant at the VMAs I think you do that
basically you're basically Beyonce et
also spoke with Rachel on day two of the
creative arts Emmy Awards where she
dished on the challenges of pregnancy so
far my breasts have grown about three
sizes so I yeah I think it's very
obvious I also wore a dress clearly
trying to hide it but I was gonna
because I want to talk about it on stage
of doing a bunch of I if you could only
see my right nipple has quadrants now
it's a whole thing I mean there's like
it's like there's it's split into like
four literally split into four parts
all of these crevices have materialized
that I never knew could be an iniquitous
and are they all governed by the same
like mayoral body you know one one side
communist okay and it's like Berlin
bases but it's raining in guys its et
it's et I'm sorry the congratulations
what it's a fan response in like for you
since you announced your pregnancy
yesterday oh it's been lovely if the
fans have been really nice and
supportive you know it's weird too
for something personal because I didn't
get married when I had a TV show so it's
weird for something that's personal to
be so public but people have been lovely
and generous with it
[Music]